all right hey welcome back to rhythm
with Griffin and as you can see I'm
trying to improve the situation you know
I got a different table now you know I
got the pictures are lined up straight
got some fan art that's from Willie
Perdue from Pittsburgh and you know like
I say guys we're just gonna continue to
grow and I'd like to feel like this is
some growth but I'm very excited for my
guests I have today my good friend
we're from worst fire team my other
podcast that nobody knows about but more
importantly more importantly the great
UFC fighter himself Taekwondo champion
right Taekwondo boxing the great Erich
Koch everybody so I don't know if you
watched a podcast or not uh you know
none of my guests watched a podcast but
you know I I do theme songs you know I'm
one that I'm on the theme song hunt
constantly and so this this is one of
them what I'm gonna do now is like I'm
gonna pick this one one the pole so I'm
gonna put this this is gonna be the
theme song from here on out until
somebody sends one that can beat it
you know but it's also one of my
favorites anyway and this is from
detective design versus Eli wintermen
Rob Kim oh you know octave octopod and
octave Kat that's the name of their band
this is ridiculous how like 20 of them
and there's so many so this is the one
that I just so this is gonna be so I'm
after this I'm not even gonna start the
podcast I guess I'm just gonna do the
the theme song and then lead it to the
guests but but first my guests ladies
and mr. Eric Koch UFC fighter
extraordinaire here we go
now so welcome to rhythm with Griffin
everybody
and we stank up in here
so welcome to Griffin with Griffin once
again here at riffin studios and I like
to welcome my guest mr. Eric Koch once
again I mean they really did they really
went to work with me on this man so
anyways as much as um you know we know
each other I don't know like where you
started like what's what's to start you
know so you've been in the UFC for how
long I can't even give you a year I
started with the WEC but at the time the
WEC in my weight class of 145 was still
owned by Zuffa which owned UFC so it was
still pretty much it was the same thing
it was just the where the lighter weight
classes started oh so you were on floor
kinda yeah yeah yeah and then they they
merged them because they wanted to brand
it as one single thing the UFC because
for a long time UFC didn't have
featherweight division they didn't have
145 35 25 so we were the WEC and when
they decided to merge them that's when
they merged them and nothing changed for
us but the name at the time at the time
when did they know was gonna be as big
as it was like when you were just doing
it with you just like that was as big as
it is gonna get did you even think it
was give me in the UFC
yeah just like it's just like that kind
of like a combat fighting as
entertainment I think so I think so just
because you know I I remember when I
started this when I started training in
my brother's basement so going back I
started training with my brother when I
was 12 13 oh wow my brother's basement
and this is when brothers how much older
is your brother oh yeah he's my big
brother and we started in this basement
and it was one of those things you know
I didn't do good in school
many what to do you know I wasn't I
wasn't the best so you see a problem
with authority
yeah yeah I have a problem with
authority and I was just about to say
anybody that knows me probably pick up
on that um but but no I I did Taekwondo
from for four to about eleven twelve and
then I had like a year where you know as
that awkward that awkward stage I didn't
really know what I want to do but once I
started train with my brother in the
basement I found out this is this is
what I liked cuz I did Taekwondo for so
long right I've been in combat sports
you know but I trained the first week I
did it I was like man I wanted to do
this and it was one of those things I
told my I told my parents I think I'm
done with school I'm just gonna be over
you in high school yeah I was gonna call
child services right yeah yeah yeah okay
with that they didn't like that they
didn't like that but you know it was um
there's one of those things that I just
pursue I pursued thankfully it worked
out for me but going going back to it
the UFC being as big as it I I
definitely saw it when I first started
training it was funny because they they
just had the anniversary clip-on button
UFC's Instagram but it was the forest
great I don't know if you've ever seen
the fight yet cuz you're not me I'm not
big on it it's just so violent but but
anybody that watches UFC the first
Forrest Griffin Stephan Bonnar fight
which was like it was one of the first
televised like getting it out there oh
really so happened to be one of the best
fights like it was a slugfest it's a
perfect storm yeah yeah the rules the
same the rules were pretty much okay
okay yeah they're pretty much the same
but even Dana says like that that
catapulted it like without that fight
going down the way it did it wouldn't be
as big as it is now and I kind of agree
with it it was kind of a perfect storm
but I I knew you know I knew with how
popular it was it was it was gaining
notoriety because boxing took awhile
boxing's been around for forever
whoops and it goes ups and downs but as
a man I think it's on the downright
national popularity right yeah yeah yeah
but MMA is just you know skyrocketing up
so it's I would still say it's kinda in
its niche era right now its niche era
but um I think it's it's getting you
know with your conor mcgregor's and
stuff like that it's definitely on the
uprise you said that with a little bit
of like I don't I don't hate on the man
the man he's if you look at it he can
act
he can act he puts on a good show and I
don't do I think Conor McGregor's an
that [ __ ] outside it he does some
things he shouldn't have done you know
with the whole Dali incident and you
know some stuff going on now but
honestly I got nothing against him I
think he's a he's a martial artist
through and through I just think he
found an opportunity to sell himself and
make a bunch of money you know do you
think that what do you feel about that
being being a part of it what's the line
for you like where it's like this is
entertainment but it is also a
professional fighting right how does
that mix oh so this is the the way I you
know I come from traditional martial
arts so I can be a hothead but when when
I go in there and compete like it's it's
all respect you know this is all this is
all you know I I come from you know
those Taekwondo today's I'm not I'm not
about talking trash and you know
somebody I've always looked at it if
somebody's gonna say something I'm
definitely gonna defend myself but I'm
not gonna go out of my way to to kind of
you know rough some feathers and talk
[ __ ] and I feel like what in the sport
right now we're in we're in a weird kind
of area where Conor McGregor did it so
well now you're getting all these people
trying to copycat and they're not as
good as him like cuz he's a good actor
he's a good showman he can put it on now
you got is he a better showman than he
is a fighter I think so oh I think so I
I think he's a great fighter but top of
the food chain I think there are
definitely people that are my sister see
there's probably more skilled strong
right right straight better fight got
you yeah but I'm not saying he's he's
good yeah you know but um okay I
definitely think he played it he played
it the right way he played the bad guy
and that's the thing with pay-per-views
man when you start making pay-per-view
money it doesn't
matter if they love or hate you if they
hate you and they want to see you lose
and they buy the pay-per-view you're
giving them money you know so like he
played it good but now you're getting
people like colby covington who just
cringe it makes you cringe like whenever
they talk crap you're just like the
old-school w remember remember ricky the
dragon'
you know I don't WWF no is that well I
did like Ultimate Warrior macho man for
that okay but think about ricky the
dragon' is he wasn't a good actor so he
didn't believe like macho man savage was
great yeah Ultimate Warrior was those
guys you know jake the snake' and all
these guys they had this persona yeah it
was important if you didn't have that no
matter how athletic or strong you were
it just didn't come didn't come through
well and that's that's what I feel you
know that's what I feel with this game
like this guy told me covington who he's
trying to play that and it just doesn't
it's just cringy and you're like oh he
shouldn't have done that you know so
like I don't want the sport to become
what WWE is I don't want it to all be
entertainment like people are like oh
this is a grudge match I want it like I
think if our sport is gonna last for the
long haul I think we need we need to
make it a sport not a spectacle does
that make sense no that makes perfect
and I think you know I think the fast
money I yeah the money's definitely in
you know talking [ __ ] you sell a fight
you can definitely make money for from
that but how long is that gonna last how
long are people gonna buy into that [ __ ]
you know well I mean I guess it's just
so it all depends but so then what do
you think well McGregor is he's been to
want and what's-her-face Ronda Rousey
yeah you know I mean you know she helped
propel the sport even if she wasn't even
that great at the time you know right
right right right I mean did you think
that do you think when someone rises as
fast as she did in popularity but then
that wasn't necessarily able to follow
through in the ring did that hurt or
help the sport yeah I think both I think
Ronda definitely helped a female a
female
may seem because a female MMA scene even
even Dana was like man there'd never be
there's never gonna be females in the
UFC but Rhonda gave Brant brought that
charisma that energy you know yeah yeah
yeah so like I I think I think stuff
like that's good I'm not you know I just
think for the long if we're talking like
MMA in the Olympics which is already
that's the kind of hard thing to do but
like if that's what we're trying to talk
about our sport as kind of like the long
the long term then I think we should be
more invested about the actual skill
behind the sport not so much the antics
that go and you know it is but that's
where my you struggle with this you have
a hard part you think you have a problem
with that I don't I I really don't have
a problem with it I just feel like it's
I don't want too much of either if that
makes any sense it's it's a very weird
because I can see I can say someone you
know I could get not really an argument
but I could say well I want the purity
of the sport I think it should be based
off this and then I can have some people
tell me well they're you're getting more
viewers because you got these people
that are selling it and I can't sit here
and say that they're wrong you know it's
kind of that's why I really don't think
there's a right or wrong I just think I
think for the legitimacy of the sport I
think we got to go about it maybe a
little bit of different of a different
way but I could also be completely wrong
and we could keep selling fights and as
long as people keep buying it so then
you know so then what do you think that
the Mayweather McGregor fight was that
good or bad for MMA good good for boxing
bad for boxing and that's that's a
that's it if you want to I think it was
I mean obviously big payday for for for
both of them I think it was a bigger win
for MMA because you know most people you
know you got your your your high-level
boxers and a lot of those high-level
boxers thought Connor didn't stand a
chance right it was a fight you know it
wasn't he got beat everybody I thought
he was gonna get beat I didn't think he
was gonna win
but what do you say to people that say
that holyfield was putting on now
Holyfield what's his name um maybe
whether mother Mayweather was put on a
show putting on a show and they I mean
he knew that when a time came to beat
him you know I said I said I said
because Mayweather said he was gonna
finish him just going in like analyzing
the fight yeah he was actually doing
what I said he was doing before like he
he told the crowd afterwards he was he
was implementing more of a Mexican style
you know a high guard walking forward so
I people a lot of people thought he
wasn't boxing the same way because he
was kind of carrying Conor but I think
it was just a strategic move I think he
knew he was smaller um
Connors the counter fighter just like
Mayweather Mayweather is a counter
fighter to I think I think Mayweather
knew to get him tired he had to come
forward about but what about don't you
think though that there was there's talk
that because the Pacquiao fight was such
a just a joke mm-hmm that he didn't want
to have that happen again
yeah yeah well I'm not trying to take
away from dragor right right this guy's
a he's a world-class box oh yeah yeah
well he was 49 I know at the time the
right right I mean so it's like you know
he's at the top of his game and yeah how
do those two fighting styles mesh yeah
yeah well I mean it's definitely
Mayweather's world like even even being
a good striker and MMA boxing is a
completely different sport you can do
things in boxing you can't do an MMA and
vice versa right right and well you even
see see it in that fight even the [ __ ]
hit number on top of the head and he's
like come on dude he's like you know
because we're used to clinch yeah if
they if they do that we can either get a
choke we'll take your back no see I
don't what I remember from that fight
seeing that moment I thought Oh McGregor
could kill him if he wanted to yeah Oh
like if it was like no holds bar fight
anyway no yeah cage but yeah I would
take him agree no no holds but yeah no
holds barred Mayweather would smash the
month in around it be it be game over
and that's I I like me whether I like me
whether a Gregor would the McGregor
would like if they like if they got into
an Arctic oh god it would we would be it
would be a mismatch in the same way
right right it really would I think even
worse I think
no there's there's so many variables in
boxing like I said I love boxing there's
a lot of science to it but there's rules
to it
MMA there are so many variables there's
so many ways to win so many ways to lose
so like you know that's you know that's
the thing we knew that you know even
Connor knew he was at a disadvantage but
he made he made a lot of money off that
yeah I know he made a lot of money and
Connor loses he says okay I lost so the
best boxer in boxing yeah exactly
great what is that mean what if he what
is he won and he beat arguably the best
boxer they'll be ginormous
and then McGregor becomes justice yeah
he's just a tyrant driving cars into a
bus no way with yeah yeah so okay so
let's go back so you know you tell your
parents you don't like school you're in
high school but they're like no
[ __ ] you're graduating high
school yeah so you graduate high school
but throughout high school you're
fighting did you wrestle
did you like high school wrestling let's
wait you some Cedar Rapids where you
from Cedar Rapids well let's just back
that's that whole of America
so much I guess Griffin needs some
comedy in his podcast right
no I yeah I actually you know cuz i got
i got into roof with my parents too and
they didn't let me live at their house i
actually i stopped going to school they
found out they kicked me out of the
house I lived on the street for about Oh
two months yeah yeah and you got a good
fighters here right and actually funny
cuz when I was supposed to fight Jose
Aldo for the for the title UFC came to
my hometown and they did like you know
you know how boxing does like the 24/7
like the whole documentary style like
really clean they got all this footage
and then when I when I had to are when
the fight got cancelled because I we
both got hurt even one of the camera
guys goes god that's a shame that's not
gonna go out there cuz that was like one
of the coolest cuz I showed him I showed
him you know that I remember there was
one night me and my friend at the time
we were both both homeless dropped out
of high school yeah I had a buddy that
was
you know just a bad in that in whose
idea was I'm sure was your idea it was
more yeah yeah yeah we were actually
speaking of the wrestling room we had a
way to sneak in the wrestling room
wrestling room was always super and it
was cold this time of year as in Iowa's
winter right so we'd sneak into the
wrestling room and sleep under the mats
because it was super hot yeah man yeah
so like it's one of those things I don't
want to go to teach I tell kids are be a
what do you call them inspirational
speaker or be a mentor cuz I can't go to
school would be like quit school do what
you want to do [ __ ] everybody
no any regrets I mean yeah I there
always will be but I'll tell you this
like just I'm very blessed I'm very
lucky that it went the way it did and I
think I think there's something to take
from all of it there are definitely
things you know I wish I would have
finished high school there's things I
didn't get to experience that I still
think about to this day but just stupid
you know stuff away and I'm seeing it
now I'm seeing my niece and stuff do
stuff like that like wow that's crazy
perspective but yeah but um but at the
same time you know you hear that you
hear a lot of successful people they say
don't let anyone be your boss be your
own boss and and if you want to do it
you'll do it it's not it may be harder
for you than it is for someone else
but if you really want to do something
you'll do it and I think about all the
stuff I went through and it was never a
question in my mind I I was like now I'm
gonna make this work this is what I want
to do I'm gonna work in it and it worked
so I think there's something to take
from that but at the same time I don't
want to advocate drop out of high so a
baby you know you don't have the answers
you know my dad used to say that oh
you're 16 and you got it all figured out
that was his favorite thing to say yeah
that's that's to go to yeah yeah yeah
you got it all figured out okay so
you're 16 you haven't you're you drop
out of high school yeah living in the
the wrestling room you know I mean and
then so then what
what what's next after that like man
when did it start to hat look what did
you decide to do so so luckily you know
my best friend of this day Wes guest he
wrestled and I see he was a couple years
older me in high school but he you know
he was working going to college at the
time and he had a house and he actually
like rent-free let me stay at his house
you know real cool dude let me say and
like without him doing that I I try to
think how would I like I didn't I
wouldn't even be you know what I'm
saying so I had a I had a really really
good support system the homies I did
have were that still ride-or-die homeys
I would actually my buddy Wes I was just
talking about we went and saw that
Captain Marvel s oh that's what we went
together but uh but no like I had a
really good support system and my you
know my mom was my mom's always been the
disciplinarian my dad was like the I
need to make sure everything's okay you
know he's a provider yeah yeah and when
I got kicked out my dad would it was
funny cuz my dad but who kicked you out
the mom kick you my mom kicked me out
she's like and then you can't stay here
yeah you're not gonna and then my dad
was actually helping me out oh but
keeping it from her right she found out
and they she kicked him he got into it
yeah almost
I snapped on on her no but I mean she's
just me she's doing she thought it was
best gotta kick the bird out of the nest
they you know I and so I completely
understood but um but yeah so I was I
was just living with my buddy charity
case
you know being a charity case and you
know he was uh he was providing food and
all that stuff and then I just um while
I was trained and I took my first fight
when I was 16 oh wow and I was at the
time MMA wasn't as big so it wasn't
regulated like it was now so it was it
was it was a pro rule fight but your own
you're supposed to be 18 or older right
so I lied about it and I did it and I
took it two weeks notice completely
supposed to get my ass whooped I I'm
fighting a military guy and I know you
don't know but a lot of people in the
fight community Miletich at that time
they had like all the world champs in
UFC oh this is reco fight rich
yeah like Rich Franklin Matthews a bunch
of like you know
and in his corner he's got like Pat
Miletich robbie lawler Jen's Pulver a
bunch of us see Ben so this is like a
tune-up fight yeah this is just like
Rocky yeah this is for him to win I'm
like and even even my coach Dave at the
time he brought me and he's like I'm not
I'm gonna be honest with you you're
probably pretty much he's like your
fight and I'm playing a stepping stone
yeah yeah and I'm like well [ __ ] that I
like you just threw me I'm not I'm not
doing that like I'm gonna go and win so
I went out and I dominated the fight I
ended up winning it in the third round
with a with the choke and after that the
feeling I got from it and kind of like
having everybody say oh god this guy's
so tough and then whooping his ass I was
kind of like ah I think I got something
here I think there's so you beat him oh
yeah I whooped his ass oh wow yeah yeah
it was like it was one-sided and I even
surprised myself like I think going
there to get my ass beat but I expected
me to have a lot of I've never fought
before like practice oh yeah so once I
got in there and it clicked and I did
everything that would the way I should
have and I had a good performance I'm
like I think I got something here and
then after that it was you know gung-ho
that like that's it was an obsession and
in that that took me for a while through
local circuit and then I ended up
meeting Duke Rufus who still my coach
now you know as with him in Milwaukee
lived there for 10 years
get into a feud with Milwaukee no we're
good
this guy thinks Milwaukee has better
tacos than LA I'm telling you guys I'm
not saying better but I'm telling you
our friend Craig afros gonna do a taco
shop here and I wasn't that impressed
yeah well you can't you can't have some
nerdy guy talk to you so please you hear
about this okay so one taco shop I bet
you the food was good though happy it's
probably worse than me
all right so you live in Milwaukee for
ten years so well how how I met him I
actually I went up I went up to Rufus
for it went up to Milwaukee we had a
couple buddies from my gym back home in
Cedar Rapids that cross-trained up there
with him and they said just one day
randomly they said they said come up you
should come up and train with us so I
went up there and trained and you know I
went up there that one day I met Anthony
Pettis and that was right before his WEC
debut right before he's about to me he's
fought awhile but like his first high
notch up fight and I trained with him
and then you know Duke pull me to the
side and he's like hey where you fightin
and I was like locally you know Annie
and he's like where do you want to fight
and like I told you WC at the time for
me and my weight class was the highest
week like it was the UFC was WEC right
so I was like well WEC obviously and
he's like okay okay so I go back home to
Iowa next day he calls me and I was kind
of like what I pick it up
and he's like all right son I got you a
five fight contract with WEC and I was
just like how old were you at the time I
was 19
okay so you've been so from that 16 year
old for how many fights did you have
before you got to that point eight times
eight No yeah and and he gave me the
call and he said that and like I was
like holy [ __ ] cuz that was like me that
was me fighting local circuit that's
pretty much getting the call that you're
in the UFC oh so I'm like oh [ __ ] I lost
it and now I mean that was you know I
fought a couple more at home and then I
ended up making the move to uh to
Milwaukee and Rufus sport and then I
stayed there for 10 years and I mean
that's led me to now Ronnie not been
fighting for the company for so how do
you know I'm 30 just turned 30 or not so
30 but so you feeling you're feeling
like the end is near I don't I'm just
saying I don't know what yeah what's the
shelf life hold up the fight game is so
weird because you could because guys
that are fighting their Friday you're
worried you could have a fight where it
happens
and then you start rethinking I is this
worth it um you know I've had a lot of
injuries not a lot of brain injuries but
I've had a lot of like physical injuries
physical injuries and stuff like that um
other than that like I feel good my head
feels good as long as that was not full
of high school knowledge but I know I
feel good now it's one of those things
you know I always said I wanted to end
about 35 if I have a good career maybe
maybe late like 38 I think that'll be
that'll be it if God willing there's no
engine cuz you've been you've had a
couple of oh I've had I've had a lot
I've had and fights cuz it yeah I've had
a lot of injuries but I mean luckily
like you know double-edged sword
I've got injured a lot but I haven't had
like that career-ending torque come on
we torn MCL yeah yes that completely
changed the fighter so I'm blessed in
that way so I mean getting on top of
that I think a lot of it was due to you
know I like weight training I think I
was overdoing my strength and weight
training so I've been doing more like
gymnastics stuff like that more
bodyweight more stabilization than
anything else and just be healthier
year-round oh okay so you're training
with them but is it like official
training were you training in other
places like I'm saying did you have like
a Taekwondo master did you have like oh
so I mean jutsu masters yeah yeah would
you what are you an expert in well like
you know that was the thing when when I
got into the sport it was still kind of
it was MMA was mixed martial arts right
we're starting to mix but it was still
you would still run into a lot of people
with styles right like okay this guy's a
wrestler oh this guy's a jujitsu guy
right right I've gone through that
unique period where I was a part of it
when it was those days and now it's
everybody's just good at everything you
know that kind of and which helps cuz
somebody might be have an emphasis on a
particular type of fighting right right
right and they bring that in yeah yeah
for a loop and you know that's the
biggest thing I mean I I got you know
Daniel Wanderley who is the instructor
at Rufus port who's a third degree black
belt he's a beast
that's my jiu-jitsu guy my my striking
coach obviously Duke Rufus who's a
four-time world champ and I mean
kickboxing knowledge the guy's an
encyclopedia it's it's crazy
even and it's funny too cuz like the man
truly cares cuz now that I live in Iowa
you know running gym with my brother he
sends me fight videos every single day
so he's still like making sure I'm all
my stuff but um I got him and then you
know a lot of it man like there's so
many different elements in this sport
the best thing I think where you're
seeing people excel now is not really
training one thing as as not like saying
I'm gonna take this stay and just do Jiu
Jitsu the way I feel about it more now
is you've got to train the whole sport
as a whole you've got to be ready for
the transitions between standing ground
all that stuff cuz that's where
everybody's getting good everywhere now
now it's who's better at making the
transition a good example was GSP and I
know you've heard of his name you
probably haven't you know I think you
were at a fight we I think with Bobby we
watched when he fought Bisbing he
knocked Bisbing out but um he's a good
example of he beats everybody he takes
everybody down that he fights but he
fights people that he fights wrestlers
that if he wrestled him in a wrestling
match he'd get schooled but when he
wrestles him in fighting he beats him
because his understanding of everything
the entire game is better here so I
think I think I think that's where the
sport is going and that's kind of where
my mentality is going i you know i don't
i don't like to Train I don't like to
spar without takedowns because I'm not
doing that I'm not doing a kickboxing
fight there's always the possibility of
take knows so I always want to have that
in my mind so that means I guess that
that sounds to me like the coaching is
super-important Oh super mean but in in
and you know even even Duke will tell
you Dukes not a wrestler but he kicked
he kicked box forever he's done
traditional martial arts
but he'll tell you hit the system he's
developed is more geared towards MMA now
than it is kickboxing
hmm and he's he's more of a kickboxer
right so there's definitely you know a
little subtleties little differences but
that's what's awesome about MMA because
boxing you see a lot of guys with
undefeated records right right right
because I get it well in they do a good
job pumping people up but you only got
two hands doesn't matter how good you
are an MMA you're gonna have a lot
you're gonna happen it's gonna happen
dude it's there's so many crazy but
that's the distinction between the two
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah so when you
when you were coming up like do you ever
have like those friends who were not
fighters and you know you're out
someplace and somebody's like you'll get
him I once had a guy too going on the
other end you get the the insecure the
insecure meathead male that like hears
you're a fighter and they try to call
you out so there is a funny story this
was around yeah yeah this was around
maybe I think it was 1819 but I was at a
buddy's house at a house party and
training like two days before I like
ripped a bunch of tendons in my arm my
left elbow and I literally had a sling
on right so we go to this party and
we're playing some beer pong or
something and some guy some guy looks at
me and he's kind of you know sizing me
up and I'm like what's up man
I'm like can he can I help you he's like
hey I heard you're a fighter Mike yeah
he goes you want a bot I looked down I
got a sling on I look down and I'm like
that's fair then I go you know what yeah
I'm like go get me one boxing club I'll
beat you with one hand and then he
looked at me like he's like I was
kidding I'm like knew you weren't [ __ ]
if you were trying to punt me out and
you're like yeah yeah but yeah I mean
being a like being a fighter you do get
you know you do have the buddies that
when they get drunk oh you know who this
guy is and I'm like
don't do that like I can't just be like
getting in bar bar fight a new game
that's like oh I completely back what
he's doing you know like I get in
trouble for [ __ ] like that with the law
if you're a lethal weapon well well and
and if I met a drinking establishment
it's hard to say oh who was in the right
if you're both been drinking it doesn't
look good for me either way if I get in
a fight you know if something happens on
the subway dude it's like drinking and
driving
you can't yeah right you can't drink and
fight yeah right right right yeah well I
mean it just it's it's hard cuz cuz
people say you know Oh your hands are
registered it's not really that it's I
can defend myself I can't go not not as
me getting in trouble
um no if you what the law I'm saying if
you're in a fight with someone yeah and
you physically injured that person or
kill them mm-hmm even in self-defense oh
yeah you're gonna have a trouble
defending yourself in court no if
they're lying what I do you're doing
what you do that I'm saying right yeah
you should be careful who you getting on
oh for sure for sure what and on top of
it too like you know like I said I still
having a contract with the UFC they
don't think that it makes the brand look
bad yeah you know what I'm saying like
we're supposed to be martial artists
right martial artists so we got to
present herself that way and so like
that's the one thing if I go out and I
got a buddy doing that I'm just like man
I'm so I'll tell you right now you're
getting a fight I can't really help you
I'm not your referee yeah not just
bringing me out to show muscle yeah I
hate that I hate that but luckily you
know that the older I get the less I'm
in the bar scene and my friends now are
older I really don't have to deal with
it as much anymore but so where do you
see where do you see yourself so you're
30 now 30 so what do you want to
accomplish if for you're 35 you're 35 to
38 goals right like 37 what what do you
want to say about yourself well I feel
like I feel like the biggest thing in
my MMA career I've learned a lot of
lessons just by doing things wrong like
you know I know right yeah I want to go
back but I you know I've it's been trial
and error kinda and even I think weight
weight cutting has been been a big issue
for me you know I started when I started
fighting I was starch and everybody I
was a smaller guy I fought at 155 I
wasn't nearly as big as I am now then I
went down I went down a whole weight
class when I got bigger I got bigger and
I'm like oh all these guys are cutting a
lot of weight I need to cut a lot of
weight too so I think you know my my my
biggest thing is just staying positive I
know how good I am I know the people I
train with I know they know how good I
am I know I can [ __ ] some [ __ ] up I I
started this to be a to be a world champ
and that's where I want to end it I mean
if you're a fighter and you don't want
to be a champ you shouldn't be doing it
right you know what I'm saying because
this is a dangerous game yeah if you're
doing this and it's not even as
lucrative is you wanna dance Matt it's
not but like only for like you know it's
not late NBA where ain't a minimum
salary and you know that's another thing
with MMA even you know when when I was
younger fighters made even less money to
me this wasn't about money like yeah
money's a necessity Matt we need money
but it's money's not what I want when
I'm dead I can people can go back and
say hey this guy did this you know
that's why a lot of a lot of sports
people do you know a lot of those
legends Michael Jordan will live forever
not necessarily all the money he's made
but Michael Jordan will always be one of
the goats right that's that anybody in
sports that should kind of be the end
goal you know so you so you still have
some work to do you I got work
oh oh I got a lot of work to do I got a
lot of work to do but like I said just
reinventing myself the older I get
training smarter I'm doing a lot of
things differently that I thought I
would never do to get light I like I
told you about gymnastics yeah starting
to do more gymnastics gymnastics try and
do more gymnastics because hit like yeah
yeah doing flips and handstands
no just being healthier all my joints
training smarter the older I get also me
and my brother running a gym
what's the name of the gym a hard drive
hard hard drive hard drives Performance
Center yep in Cedar Rapids Iowa Wow and
you're up there you're corn-fed and you
aren't fat man yeah you want to get your
fight on but no we're also affiliate of
of my coach Duke Rufus okay your school
they're two for from Milwaukee Milwaukee
yep that's Rufus sport they got that far
away though right new is three three and
a half oh okay actually my brother my
brother and spud our business partner
are up there right now
they just rubble right now got a
business meeting with those guys but um
but yeah running that so I'm still
training three times a day but I'm also
teaching three four classes a day and
what I'm what I'm starting to realize is
the older I get just going over the
fundamentals like any sport fundamentals
are the most important thing I go over
the same fundamentals over and over and
over and they actually make my game so
much tighter just reinforcing now do you
see a young coke out there when you're
when you're with these kids do you see
somebody you're like how that kid's
gonna I yeah oh yeah oh so you see
you're so transitioning into code you a
coach I love coach yeah I love coaching
and it you know it's that's another
thing like in in a competitive way it's
hard to take in a competitive edge away
from someone who's competed their entire
life right I think that's the next I
want to you know I want to help others
reach those goals kind of like I did you
know but but saying even that you know
thirty people say thirties prime I've
been doing I know I've been doing this
for a long time but I still got that
that spark you know I want to I want to
coach I want to help out but I still got
you know I have my own goals that my
window is closing so I want to make sure
that you know I put in as much work as I
possibly can
well that's great man I like to hear
that you know I know you had to like bow
out of the last fight for an injury so
do so when when the next fight is that a
read you're gonna be able to fight that
same person honestly I don't know it's
it's at a good spot where it could I
mean he's just coming off a win but I
know the guy you were gonna for the guy
was gonna fight but I mean with with the
division right now I try to think of
people
like realistically they would match me
up with and I'm not sure I mean he's one
of them
there might be another five six eight I
mean it's such a deep division but it's
just one of those things that my biggest
frustration my MMA career like I said
going back to weight cutting is I've
always had to take a lot of time before
a fight just to get my body to where it
needed to be now that I'm fighting one
side even even even here right now I'm
I'm walking around about 183 184 I could
cut to 170 in a week so I want a Donald
Cerrone this [ __ ] which anybody knows
Donald Cerrone I want to take start just
taking fights start knocking them off
because that's what you know getting
your name out there fighting is a brutal
business in that you win a fight and
everybody's on you for that weekend and
then after that who you fight next yeah
you know what have you do for me like
yeah it's very short-lived so it's one
of those things I just want to get my
name out there and keep it out you know
keep it out there I think that's the
best way to to go up the ladder but um
seeing my my teammate Anthony Pettis
have a lot of success against wonderboy
in his last fight going up 70 everybody
thought he was gonna be too small he
ended up knocking him out cold like that
and this is the stuff like I know like I
said I know what I can do I've trained
with 170 years I'm not getting bullied
around I'm not getting muscled around
you feel like this is your target weight
this is where I need to be this and I
should honestly I should have been here
for a while now you fought at higher and
lower
I thought all lower our lows I fought at
145 and then I fought 155 that was the
last weight class I was at now moving up
to ones that don't you got you yeah
wait it makes a big big difference
especially the older you get I noticed
when they wouldn't you're young you can
cut that weight your body can kind of
recover the older you get
hang in there 295 weight class life yeah
but I'm gonna go I'm gonna go back
thanks for calling me out yeah yeah yeah
well that's good man listen you know we
got a I got a show tonight - you know
cokes in town we're gonna go watch
Avengers maybe we'll even have him come
back
we're gonna talk about it I'll be cool a
little movie review do a little little
in-game movie review it at movie review
at the end of this so on top of this we
might be looking different different
clothes and all that kind of stuff but I
did want to get you on I wanted to talk
about you your story and and it's great
I like like you're passionate about this
I feel like you're you know I hope you
achieve the thing that you want to
achieve but it sounds to me like you're
gonna still be content no matter what
happens because you're always gonna be
in the fight game always always in some
form yeah you know it's it I've been
doing it for so and like you said poke
make more more graduation jokes are you
know like what else am I gonna do right
what but you know that's another thing
our game you know I told my mom because
my mom we're going back to that my mom
would always be like well what do you
you need a fallback you need this I'm
like I'm like but at the same time and
it's crazy because I wouldn't think
about it the way I do like an 16 year
older the way I think about now that I
come in 16 year old it's like well that
means I got to make it work then doesn't
and there's that's crazy but there's
some realness on because I feel like I
did that we got to comedy have this like
back this thing you know it means you
don't really believe in in what you're
doing yeah yeah yeah so it's I don't
know it's kind of crazy but but I'll
always be involved in this regardless of
of what I'm doing but um teaching
teaching something that I didn't think I
would enjoy as much and I thankfully
I've had you know a good teacher with
Duke and I have people tell me you know
I remind him remind them of Duke when he
teaches and I can see it because once
you're influenced I'm yeah it is 19 he's
he's such a good teacher so III didn't
think it'd think of it in that light I
thought okay he he's gonna help me with
my my my fight career you know
but now that I'm coaching I'm like dude
like if I didn't have him as a coach I
wouldn't be able to even do what I'm
doing right now you know what I'm saying
so he's reached me on so many other
levels I wasn't even conscious about you
know Wow cool yeah that's cool yeah well
I'm glad you are
I'm glad you in town glad you
came on like I say I do I wish you the
best you know it's like I can't I don't
like watching you fight yeah you know
because it's like it's rough you're it's
just I just don't like seeing that yeah
all that but I will I will say this I do
want to come to a fight and I wanna I
want to have them cornered I want to be
in the corner yeah as long as I got
keone and Duke I would like to have
because you can have three right gonna
have 300 yeah so I could put you in
there because a lot of people like to
have you know yeah I know but like I
just think it'd be funny for people
being like is that personally two
corners are perfect for me because like
in a corner how you got a minute in
between rounds right am I really talking
to three people yeah like I'm I'm
focused on that guy you know I got I got
one person give give me two people
giving me instruction the thirds just
there for moral gotcha
yeah am i throwing the towel start a
second fight throw the towel you were
about to win oh my bad
but hopefully it's gonna be awake you do
have a fight scheduled though no well I
I thought I was gonna have it now I'm
just waiting now okay I guess yeah stay
tuned
yeah I don't wanna I don't want to put
any dates okay wait what stay tuned me
and most of my Vegas or some place I
tell them I'll always fight in Vegas
yeah and Craig as if I'm thinking of
Craig right Craig is like you got to get
a fight close to here get it to fight
close to here so we can come watch my
god you think I'm thinking about you
coming to my fight I'm about to fight
another [ __ ] human being dude I could
care less what you think Oh
yeah well okay you know what we're gonna
in there for now because this might be
the end of this podcast or next thing
you know boom we got this movie review
you know what I mean so Wilson I'm not
sure yet but I did want to have my man
on it's in town in LA so you know when
your friends come in town they do some
great things like this guy does I got to
have them on so I really appreciate you
coming on and uh thanks know and good
luck you know I'm gonna see I wanna I
wanna know hey my friend is a world
champion yeah hopefully it does go to
the Olympics like extreme sports
yeah they got people jumping on [ __ ]
skateboards my god people fight MMA for
a well you'd love to fight for America
and I think great I think it I think you
could what you just said right there I
think that's why it could happen because
it's blowing up all over yeah yeah it's
everywhere like every way and Fighting's
have been around
beginning a man to and kind you know
like fighting even wrestling wrestling's
the oldest work there Brett wrestling's
in the Olympics you know I think it'll
happen but MMA still super young you
know it's not that's true and how can
they police it in the Olympic let me
somebody can actually like you know
somebody could get seriously hurt and
then they can't go on to the next round
where I it'll probably be teams but
thing to them in boxing is actually more
dangerous than MMA I well I think the
boxing is more dangerous to the person
for long term yeah but I'm talking about
boat with then you can still finish like
is that me but how many boxing matches
are there in Olympics like to get to win
go like how many fights do you have to
fight cuz they're only like three round
fights pretty much 515 round right right
three weeks by man like I'm sitting a
puppy B teams it would be like this team
and then like so you hit you one person
can fight and if that person gets
injured you still have somebody but if
all three get it that's when they're
eliminated and kind of like two teams
like and like you you're talking like
United States yeah yeah do that and then
have like weight class
yeah well yeah obviously yeah yeah just
have like like a wrestling meet yeah
yeah you just got somebody for every
weight class but I mean I could
definitely see it happening it's just
yeah it's a young it's a young sport but
I mean if they got
power walking in the [ __ ] I know I know
but that's Louis back you know you know
but there's a lot of [ __ ] nobody thinks
knows can get crushed it's [ __ ] crazy
I know I know I know that curling one is
the one that I don't want to be that I
want to be the [ __ ] duster guy you
don't want the funniest part about that
is like they're talking to each other
yeah you watching it so you're right
MMA can make it to the Olympics let's
put it as a hashtag you know and maybe
Olympics but anyways just Eric hope this
is a rhythm with Griffin thanks for
listening guys thanks for watching
thanks for listening please smash that
subscribe button share like make some
comments I'm still trying to improve the
podcast and I appreciate all your
feedback and thank you
[Music]
[Applause]